if you take my rook odds challenge can
you do a blindfold as well okay
blindfold rook odds
this'll be fun
wait i don't where's my blindfold
okay i couldn't find my blindfold
but i found this
this is a grand chest tour face mask not
the most comfortable
but it'll do it blocks my vision
okay if you're just joining i'm about to
uh
depart from the visual world
hopefully
things don't go wrong
okay e4
did that not work
why can't i hear anything
unmute
volume
save
okay there we go
let me turn the volume down a little bit
okay
i did cheat for the first move
okay um c6 let's play knight f3 knight
f3
d5
this isn't so comfortable
that covers my nose too
uh d5 knight c3
knight c3
so we're having a
two nights carol khan
d4
okay that's better
d4 uh knight
e2 92
white six minutes 41 seconds okay
black four minutes 43 seconds there's no
increment
c5
knight g3
okay so i'm happy with the opening
because we're getting a more clue
structure
e5 e5 wait e5 e5
e5
knight g3 e5 the pawn just hanging
i think the pawn is just hanging
knight takes e5
knight f6 yeah usually knight um
[Music]
not knight uh c5 is better than e5
f6 bishop c4 bishop c4
i mean i'm still down with rook but now
for a pawn
so hitting f7 bishop e6 white six
minutes 13 seconds
black for form bishop takes east f takes
e6
sippity sippity sippity sippity sippity
sippity sippity tea oh yeah sip tea
which i don't have right now
unfortunately or do i i have coffee
i really have coffee
bishop d6
so bishop d6 i'll play f4 f4
reinforcing the knight
i'm allowing that file to open
[Music]
sippity sippity sippity sippity d3
i have to be careful trading too much
and maybe i should have
yeah i should have retreated the knights
fe-5
f take c
knight fd7
all right fd7
we're offering the rook trade now i'll
play bishop f4 bishop f4
knight c6
okay
uh maybe queen
queen h5
queen h5
okay so a couple attackers against the
pawn
g6
yeah g6 okay i'll play queen g4 queen g4
so hitting e6
i mean e6 is defendable
queen e7
yeah queen e7 is a good move
hmm
i'm not thrilled here
i guess i'll play knight h5
knight h5 idea knight takes e5 queen
g3 white five minutes 16 seconds
black two minutes 42 seconds okay plenty
of time
queen f7
queen f7
i have to be really really careful
[Music]
i think i'll play
queen g
oh no not queen g3
rook
f3 rook f3
rook f3
all my pieces on the king side
knight c takes e5
wow
oh that's a good move
uh
i have to take
should be five bishop takes e5
but my queen has hit two
[Music]
uh i'm in big trouble
[Music]
takes takes
i don't have knight f6
i'm looking for tricks here
i wrote f7 rick takes f7 knight takes g4
okay
rick takes f8
wait why was it not check
rook takes f8
rick takes f8 check
rick takes f8
rook takes f8 oh that was pre-moved
that's why
i see okay knight g3 knight g3
okay so i'm still down the full rook
93
um
[Music]
c3 c3
h5
there's still a pawn on d4
c takes d4 there is
oh no
wait
c takes d4 when did black play c5
okay h4
h4 h4
why 2 minutes 59 seconds
black one minute 56 seconds
very dangerous position
[Music]
h4
h4 okay
opponent's turn
rick f4
okay f4 let's play knight
e2 92.
hitting the d-pawn and the rook
brook takes pawn i take the pawn with my
knight
rook f1 check
king h2 king h e5
e5 good move
i'm stuck
i do have
knight g1 knight g1
kings on g8
rook f2
knight f3
brook takes g2 check
king h3
brook takes b2
hmm
wait where's the knight it's on e3
it's on f3
i don't know what to do
[Music]
net h2
am i losing more pawns
i gotta maneuver the night somehow
rick takes h2 check
ah i wanted rook a2 and then knight f1
knight takes f1 still meets
okay king h2 king takes h2 king f7
uh king g3 king g3 king e6 king f3
king d6
a4
king c5
king e2 b king d2
b takes a4
king c1 king b4 i should probably resign
king b1 a3
king a1
king c3 king a1
a3
k8 king b4
king a1
g5 king b1 g takes h4
king h3
king h2 king a2 h1 promotes to queen
stalemate right it's celie's i think
it's still mates
let's go i'm so happy
i had to time it too because
if i play king a2 first
then it doesn't work i have to play king
b1 and then king a2
ah
okay
g5
i'll explain
man that was tough
it's tough not having a rook
um
yeah i should not have allowed too many
trades
like maybe it's better just to like go
back and keep things safe
but
uh
i mean black played well
and i take z5 very nice to
counter-attack the queen and
uh
yeah i mean my knights hit so i had to
basically trade
rook g7 doesn't help me
might still hit
and then i'll explain my thought process
when i played
knight h2
i
i was expecting rookie too then i was
gonna play knight f1
and try and pretend it was like a type
slip and say
oh wait a minute that hangs a knight
and if my opponent takes it's stalemate
so that was my original intention
[Music]
um of course it's probably
better practically to take the pawn
but uh anyway thanks alex warner for the
the game the challenge